okay hello everyone my name is Melissa
Flores I am a grandmaster I live in
Minnesota and I'm here for a couple of
weeks is basically defined by these four
points in the center see for each for
each six and six and I really want to
make sure that you're not confused if
the point is one is seven that's a
completely super separate thing okay the
very different ideas so then I want to
show you this position so you have a
general idea for what are the standard
positions or standard squares for each
piece so you will see the night on
before 9 23 the Bishop's on this diet
and also very important and then what do
you think is the main idea that white is
aiming for here anyone can give an
answer B 5 C 5 C 5 I agree with you see
fire is very strong and something that
you will notice is a when we play C 5
maybe some points will be traded
maybe these four points B 6 d 6 C 4 and
before will go away but when that
happens then these lines will be open
the diagonals will be open and then this
wing would be in a very bad spot and
then probably we will win the pawn on e6
and then after that it will just be an
easy win because we'll be will have a
healthy pawn up this position I would
say is a clear advantage for white but
now I show you this yeah just where you
have a general idea for what to aim for
if you had this position with white and
then one big idea what do you think is
the amazing that black wants to do the
heads were typically black wants to
break in the center right so d5 is the
main idea we're thinking of and if black
were to play d5 right now what we do is
take take and then play C 5 right in
this position it is right to play so I
would just play C 5 but let's say that I
didn't do that now I just play some
silly move then D 5 and now C 5 this is
very good for white again you will
notice two things in this position after
I took the diagonal for this Bishop is
permanently blocked right the bishop is
sort of trapped the pawn on d5 is
isolated and you
cannot even move this pawn because I
intentionally have a knight on d4 right
that's why we put it there to begin with
okay so now let's move on and let's look
at the next example so save No okay so
then here we will see some standard
games so first we begin with the opening
I'm not gonna pay too much attention to
the exact move orders because what I
really want to discuss today is middle
name I want to discuss the main plans so
now is 64 and then a three why typically
play say three for two reasons number
one is that I want to prevent this
picture from coming to d4 two to bother
me and then number two is that I want to
make sure that I will be able to play
before sometime in the future so now
black played b6 which would be three all
of this is relatively standard and now
before now in this position let's look
at it from White's perspective first
let's say that we want to play as well
as possible with white then I have three
main plans incompatible ok one you have
to know which one to go for so you could
do see if I break b5 break or a5 break
they can all be acceptable but you have
to kind of make a decision by far the
most common is to break with c5 it's the
most natural and it is what we are gonna
see in this game next I will show you
some games words other ideas occur so
now it was rooks yet King each one and
by the way the reason that people play
this King is that sometimes black might
play something like Queen b8 and then
maybe be shop there maybe Bishop c7 you
see there is a threat on h2 so now
you're playing d5 and threatening so
what I can do is I can play Bishop which
it one and then everything continues to
be defended
now in this game after before okay so
King Ashwin Bell just paid rookie 8 the
idea is to sort of try to attack this
Bishop whenever we try to break in the
center then white played Queen to rock
the one I'm going to notice that you
know if you were playing white in this
position okay you don't really need to
think that much right there is a finite
amount of things that you need to be
worried about now the number one thing
that you should be looking at is d5 so I
would say that you know a serious player
in this position every move he makes he
will think can you play the five so for
example I would play rook the 1 and I
would be calculating in my mind
can you play d5 right now what happens
it takes it takes them no even better
what about well you just take here so
you take your opponent retakes okay
you're a pawn up if your opponent
retakes oops we are upon up so that's
that's a very typical tactic right it's
like everything gets traded on on d5 and
then the pawn on e6 is hanging now let's
say that instead of taking you play d5
hoping to take next move well I now have
96 or Knight a 5 like you are saying
either way why he's doing great here
so after rook the one here black just
played 95 attacking this pawn then
Knight f4 and then here white played
Bishop a funny sort of like a
preparation of not very meaningful
another thing that white could have
played is just Roxy to with the idea to
play rugby one and then Quincy one that
would have been powerful as well
preparing this b5 this if I break but
instead so here we're just play Bishop
f1 black play 97 okay all now we're
going right defending edge 2 then B
group B 1 you can guess what the next
move will be
Quincy one right so let's say you just
wait for a moment
what's your evaluation of this position
can you take a guess
working can you tell me what do you
think oh why should be better here how
much it slight advantage or clear clear
okay so let's see some concrete replies
so let's say your opponent takes with
the b-pawn beat takes your we are
attacking the Queen our opponent moves
the Queen then we take on the six and we
won the game because there is a pin so
our opponent cannot retake I think we
are just winning a piece okay so that's
one possibility
what about B should be B 7 C 6 that's
also winning right like this is winning
how about when when I play here my
opponent tried to block this diagonal so
just play b5 okay I could go back and
start kind of defending but that's not
what I'm gonna do I'm gonna continue
going forward then now that I have freed
this square I will use it with my knight
what do you think of this position
what's white going to do next
a 46 both of them are good so if your
opponent play something like Bishop c6
trying to prevent c6 then I play a four
and I'm probably going to win a pawn
right there and then I have a very clear
advantage nearly decisive ok so then
this break is kind of deadly right so
after Queen c1 black play Bishop the 8th
oh no this no this didn't happen in the
game so it was Ruby 1 and black just
play we should be seventh trying to
block the Queen but then c5 right away
now there are no good responses for
white for black because for example if
he takes on c5 and we take and they play
b5 then I have a nice response c6 when
you take on a four I'll just take on b7
and this is already decisive advantage
for what can you see this
yep
so after c5 the game just continued b5
and as I was telling you previously we
are not gonna go back
if we go back notice what will happen
won't take oh well actually just 96
right away and then you know maybe we
trade and then this is like nothing
special this is just plain equality so
what we do after b5 is we play c6
standard idea our opponent takes we can
take play 96
now these two bishops are annoying right
so if I move the Queen what do you play
with white
neither a7 right so you play Knight a7
attacking the rook and if your opponent
removes the robe you win the bishop so
in the game after ninety six black
actually just to consist six white took
he won this pawn and if you won the game
the reason is simple right basically we
have broken on the Queen side we're up
on down momentarily but we are about to
win two points and we have these two
bishops that collaborate to collaborate
with with each other very well so this
should just be a win for way so overall
this games an example of the c5 break
okay let's go back then well let's go to
the next game
the opening is very similar now I will
show you here black is doing something
tricky he hasn't played this six and the
reason is that for example if I played
Bishop e2 Castle castle then black is
thinking about playing Bishop d6 so as
you can see black is basically saving
this move in reserve because if I play
g3 right now the point is to take in
that animated draw so a lot of people
when they play this with white they get
a little bit confused don't know what to
do but a simple solution for this is to
just delay the castle so you continue
making your other moves your your you're
going to play the rook on c1 anyway your
plan to play before anyway so you
continue doing this first so Roxy 1b
should be too and then eventually black
just runs out of moves
has to play these six
okay now why do we play King Ashe one do
you remember
should be one okay anyone other than you
do you remember your opponent will pay
so basically your opponent will pay
queen b8 bishop da Bishop c7 right so
now let's see why do we have to play it
now like this a game the right plate so
obviously here's something important you
don't prevent a threat before it is a
threat right that's just a waste of time
so the question is why didn't I play
Queen d2 here's the answer Queen B eight
let's say that I try to do it now and I
play something like this in my opponent
got 85 and then Bishop
attacking the exchange and then when I
cover I would lose this one and then the
night will come to age five and that
will be kind of dangerous
so that's kind of the reason right so
king ash one then black plays Queen b8 -
okay now remember what I just described
I'm afraid that my opponent will play if
I play this that my opponent will play
Bishop c7 attacking and when I defend
the fight will be annoying so instead I
played Roxy - why do I play Roxy - you
into play Ruby one so two reasons three
reasons I put the rukon C - so that I
can play route big one I want to get
away from this diagonal to make sure
that the bishop cannot come to bother me
and number three I want to play c5 right
okay 57 okay attacking this pawn I go
back then of course I'm calculating what
happens after d5 right but I know that
this is going to be fine
why is it fine what do you do
what is your name ah Felix Felix what do
you do
whoa whoa be careful know your opponent
your opponent plays d5 butter in your
center you have to take this is a
standard response you don't even need to
think about you take so you take with
this pawn this point first to open the
diagonal okay your opener it takes
uh-huh
take with the night okay then Felix what
do you do here okay so all these pieces
have been traded then what's the point
even better something else
Bishop takes standard this is very
standard okay all right that's good okay
so after Bishop g1 then D Phi is not
possible my opponent here played rook e8
which is kind of standard right
activate the rook a little bit and not a
nitrate 4 so now I'm getting closer to
playing c5 and I'm also thinking that
after d5 I will have a different
response okay you what is your name
Jason so if your opponent plays d5 right
now what do you do
you mean take on the fire yeah okay
which one you mean this okay
yes and this is looking more like
equality right you're not winning any
pawns right now right like when we try
to take there it's defended and then if
we can do that and the bishop will come
here and that will be unpleasant here's
another idea so when your opponent plays
d5 and you can't win a pawn
what you do is you take with the a pawn
sorry here not d5 pawn takes pawn take
and now c5 very good why do we play this
we have consolidated the pawn on d5
now that Bishop has a block diagonal the
pawn on d5 is isolated and the pawn on
c5 is powerful kind of passed pawn right
so it can move forward even more become
very unpleasant so if your opponent were
to take maybe you could take later you
could play c6 that would be extremely
annoying for your opponent very hard to
deal with so that's what I would do
so that's why the fight was not possible
my opponent just played 95 now what we
have been saying previously is I wanted
to play rugby 1 can you tell me why why
do we play rugby 1
what are we preparing yes how C 5 C 5
right because then these lines will
become open and then this rook and this
rope would be very active very
aggressive now I wanted to do that okay
but I didn't there the reason is that I
was concerned my opponent was gonna take
here and then my two rooks and in line
and then when I remove I was thinking
this is gonna be kind of confusing I
wasn't a hundred percent sure how to go
here because I have two pieces for the
rook which is typically good but I'm two
pawns down my opponent doesn't have many
obvious weaknesses so I was a bit
worried so I found that a simple way to
approach this was to just play here and
then I'm still preparing this break now
let's look at this break for a moment
let's say my opponent is nothing like
wait then I will push and then my next
thought will be something like pushing
right and then bring the knight and then
here or here I have plenty of threats
like I have this diagonal and that
diagonal and it's all very annoying so
this is just not a situation that you
would ever want to be in with black so
here my opponent must have thought for a
while
decided that you know the the healthiest
way to prevent this problem was both
when playing 96 his thinking was if I
push he will take and now I don't have a
pond to push he has locked
so now the question for you would be
what do you do pawn to c5 okay well so
if you play pawn to c5 ah yeah so do you
notice that this is kind of blocked a
little bit blocked now let's talk about
b5 then so if you play b5 then your
opponent will do something with the
night because the night and attack so
take and now ninety seven to the Fendi
spawn now I want to ask you what do you
think about these pawns on b5 and c4 are
they good are they bad are they weak
what do you think they are kind of
blocked you know and are they stronger
weak they're a little bit weak right why
because there's the c5 squares like a
whole right so when you look at this
position you don't feel that good right
I'm not saying this is bad but at least
it has an ugly appearance right and
that's a little bit concerning now there
is one idea that I want you to consider
is that when you do this this point is
also kind of weak deponent b6 and maybe
if you had a little bit more time you
will be able to attack it effectively so
then when we go back we realize that
instead of playing b5 design idea you
take and then b5
so it's the same as before just with an
extra temple and now things tend to work
out for us so let's see some variations
the first variation you should not
really look at is what happens if your
opponent takes and then remove the
bishop somewhere yeah how do you play
go ahead
night xb6 your opponent takes your night
now you trade everything on c8 and game
over we are a pawn up and we have some
pass pawns we will be able to win this
do you have a question no no okay okay
okay so it seems like Bishop there does
not work if you play Bishop d7 trying to
protect your rook the same line does not
work but now that you have played Bishop
d7 I can always play as Queen before and
I'm winning the pawn yeah yeah you can
play okay I can also play this right one
way or the other it will be the same
problem right or you can play e5 and
then I can play Queen them one way or
the other this is not going to be a
position you can hold so here after I -
can i play b5 my opponent just remove
his Bishop and now I need to be kind of
careful if I just hang around like rugby
1 or something he play f5 then maybe
Bishop before 97 then the knight will
maybe go to c5 and it's not gonna be
very clear that I have an advantage
right he will be able to consolidate so
I need to make the best use of my time
and what I will do is take this bomb
okay so I am a pawn up but the pawn is a
double pawn is kind of in the border so
a my opponent plays this what should I
do
think about this carefully because if
you do nothing your opponent will
eventually bring the Queen the bishop to
c6 the knight to c5 and then maybe you
will lose this point you will have no
advantage of 93 and what are you trying
to do
but that seems like a good idea okay now
oh I didn't play that but when I'm sure
the 93 just about the same so let's see
you will see that it's about the same
position so after would be one I'm
preventing 95 to sell just take and then
I'm kind of certain to win upon so my
hope I have to play there and then
Knight c3 and then might be five so Adi
what do you do now whoa if you do that
maybe I'll pin you right
how about same idea different move yeah
so then black plays rook c6 Queen d2 now
maybe you're wondering well what if my
opponent takes the pawn is that possible
no because winning right so here black
played a 5 in 5
then Brooke the one trying to claim the
file now maybe you're wondering well
what about Queen now how do you win now
Felix I think you have the move what is
the move
oh okay - then what's the next one
No
attack the bishop
now trap the Queen a very nice sequence
so we can basically play rook t1 and
claim the file and why do I play this
because I want to make sure that you can
regroup your night
so now Queen d4 I double now why is this
not okay
yeah
what were you thinking
mm-hmm yeah
yeah I can be sir who can be sullen very
good and then that's just annoying right
this is worse so in the game it was rook
here than bishop now finish for trying
to become a line and okay so basically
in this position white is upon up and
eventually won so we have seen two ideas
then we have seen what happens when you
play c5 and we have seen what happens
when you play b5 this idea of playing b5
is kind of tricky and the reason is
tricky is that when you play this move
it looks like your pawns also become
kind of quick but if you can play some
quick plan like you suggested you know
with 93-95 and then take all like he
suggested sorry then the knight c3 then
I prefer that you can get up on up so I
would say just just what you know this
b5 typically not a good idea but if you
can do it with a gain of ten point you
can quickly attack the sponson v6 and
the six it can help you to win material
and I have actually played this with
black and lost because I didn't realize
my opponent was going to make this break
so let me close this gaming go with the
next one
so here black paid a little bit
imprecisely by playing by playing this
d6 right away this is not nice
you will notice one difference between
this game in previous games in previous
games white played a a3 to prevent the
shop before but here why didn't and if
white didn't then with black you should
probably play something like 96
well maybe Bishop e7 but you should keep
the option of going to be for open
instead black just played d6 and
completely missed this idea because now
that I didn't play 3 I to pay for right
away and now with black what would you
do for example can you play a 5 this is
not pretty right like for example I
attack your Queen you move I attack the
pawn you defend it I attack the pawn on
d6 and you have lost upon and then you
will lose the game so this is not good
so if you're not going to be able to do
that then a 4 basically you can't
prevent me from playing a5 and after I
play a 5 I have achieved the 3rd break
right we talked about c5 b 5 now we are
talking about a fight break so what's
the point of this idea when I play a 5 I
immediately click create contact and I
make the opponent a 6 more vulnerable I
also activate this rook and again a
little bit of space so positionally this
is probably very hard for black to play
the only problem is that it is typically
not possible so for example if black at
play Bishop e7 and I had tried this then
you gotta just play maybe 96 and then I
don't know you can take and then it's
not very likely that I will be able to
break here because if I do it then when
I try to regain the pawn I'm not able
right ok I do this and then
this is actually better for black so
black cannot made a mistake when he
decided to close by playing this I'm
sorry white made a mistake when he
decided to close by 26 so then a 4 a 5
check what's in evaluation of this
position
slightly better for wine right
okay and then black to work
now if you were white how would you play
here
what do you think she'll be your next
goal before and then well I mean be
careful with what you're trying to do
what's the goal of playing be fine let's
say that I'm not going to do anything so
with black I'm just going to wait for
you just gonna let you play you said be
five okay because you can do the five I
will trade and then what have you
accomplished here palm traits are
typically not very helpful if if what
you're trying to do is win right maybe
you could take with the pawn that will
be more attractive but if you take with
the pawn then you also make it easy for
me to break in the center overall I'm
not seeing an advantage here at least
not a very serious one so no I would say
that white should be more focused on
trying to play before and c5 maybe and
try to target the pawn on a six because
that's the really weak bond we don't
want to trade we want to attack it so
then this game continued with 96 take
take
now before
this is about clear advantage I hope you
can see that Felix you have a question
no just stretching okay good
no it is black to move okay now just
wait to move do you have a suggestion
how to play oh that's a good question
why can you play d5 okay so let's say
you play d5
it takes it takes and c5 we discussed
this before right does this idea still
work is this a still good
what do you think is this still good or
not I mean okay is this good for white
yes or no and why yeah it is good for
white why because okay the bishop there
is not particularly good why else
because okay we got to put these two
rooks and attack this pawn on d5 and
then okay we have these two points are
kind of past very annoying so here the
game continued king of fate c5 and now I
played this very nice trick b5 so then
the point here is that if you dare to
take you're losing oh well actually I
can just play that that's even easier
I'll win a whole exchange and then I
will win the pawn on c5
so after b5 black played there a5 and
white one dissenter okay the rest is not
too important the overall idea that I
would like you to get from this is that
positionally yeah just by looking at
this position you can see that the idea
of playing a4 and a5 is very powerful
okay so let me close this and see the
next one
now at this point you might be wondering
how to fight back with black so this is
what I will show you now at least one
example of how to play with black okay
the opening is almost always the same
result which is this position
and now plug play the king is [ __ ] so
this is the beginning of an interesting
plan this plan was first played by
Fisher about 40 years ago and the idea
here is that black will play Ruby g8 and
then we'll play g5
so let's first try to understand why is
this a good idea at all is this risky
for black do you think this is weakening
for the king like if I just hang around
and I play this for example and then
this is this King on a shade unsafe why
not
most pcs are facing the Queen side
that's one reason another reason is that
the pawn structure around the pond is
very healthy if you look at the spawns
there are no major holes for example if
i push f5 you would be a different story
because then I will come to a5 and that
would be unpleasant book if I push the
five the 95 that would make things
unpleasant but as it is right now it
seems like black skin is pretty safe now
in addition to that there is a
positional reason for playing g5 let me
explain that to you when I play g5 I'm
kind of discouraging you from playing a
fork and because of that I would be more
you I will more easily be able to place
a knight on e5 with a very good position
so now let me ask you I give you this
position how do you want to play with
white
Jason
so you know what's coming right I'm
gonna play rook g8 g5 and then probably
g4 oh you can but if you do that then
maybe I can play it d5
oh yeah
so the problem in this position is that
white has played g4 so I break the
center you have played g4 it's kind of
like the chances are stacked against you
right I'm not saying your position is
bad I'm just saying that it's not as
good as it could have been a moment ago
which is why most people who play white
in this position will not be tempted to
play you four will try to stay away from
that as much as possible
okay I'm sorry solute frozen
yeah we are back
so g4 that's not the concern that I have
in the game
why just play Bishop f1 group g8 okay
here we go
now I play this three obviously why
black really wants to beat you for so H
five is natural it's not very good but
it's not terrible yet now when you look
at this position what about g4 maybe
that's different because if I play d5 my
king is already much more exposed and it
was a minute ago right because I already
moved g5 + h5 and this square is
available now
so that might have been an option now
what black can do now is 95 and the
night is very powerful only five the
people typically don't like to allow
that which is why this didn't happen in
the game in the game
why just paid queen of 22 okay attack in
the pond we push
now can you take on it on g4 ah yes and
then I will take and then the e4 pawn is
hanging and then the the line is very
unpleasant as well
so after g4 the game will continue upon
take one take one
and then Bishop g5 trying to pin so now
take okay so let me ask you how would
you continue with black obviously things
are going reasonably well for you
how will you improve from here
Queen a8 let's see that
I'm playing Queen h4 check and that's
very dangerous
right and then can you wink in G here
all rook g6 looks very good
okay yeah I think so right because the
Queen eight didn't add too much to the
position it gave me a temple right so
rock g6 was the move the idea is to just
bring the other Brooke we have some
pretty simple ideas now positionally
speaking I would say that white never
would want to trade here because if he
does then suddenly your dark squares are
very powerful right and then this pawn
is weak and then the e that Square is
weak yeah and you can feel you know kind
of delays and absence of a dark square
bishop we really need that bishop so in
the game it was Queen f4 look check here
well obviously we like blacks position a
lot and now I play Bishop d3 how do you
play now with black rook a shade okay we
like that then yeah that's one reason
but there is a deeper reason so he's
saying na - five I agree with that that
that's the right move but what's the
reason exchanging the dark square Bishop
that's very important right that piece
is holding White's position together
after we get rid of it White's position
will be very hard to play so going
beyond technical tactical details I
would say that here this is the one way
where blacks position becomes a winning
so Knight is 5 then Queen moves
take take 95
now we have these two lines open a lot
of pressure we have a powerful night
only five and we don't have any real
witnesses to worry about
and now the game just continued Bishop
e2 Queen d8 attacking the knight okay
continue many many good moves right now
Queen h4
which one
I mean sure I mean but now it's getting
messy I mean you're probably still
winning somehow but but you have mash
mash simpler ways to win this game right
so you should have gone for something
else
so after okay so it was 93 this is what
was played what is the threat with 93 Oh
Luke takes is three perfect so basically
if I do nothing then take and then check
end of the game so in this game white
played 94 and then black just played
check and then 95 that's a very nice way
to end the game because when you take
then there is a check check in the mate
so let's go back let's see how this
happened okay
obviously at this point these are
already going very well the way that we
were able to create this opportunity was
by breaking with g4 right so then one
critical plan that we have for black in
this position instead of trying to break
in the center with this fight would be
to just play King in shade and then try
to go for that now you might be
wondering well is this overall is it
good or bad and I would say that it
depends on one critical idea the
critical idea is whether white will have
time to play see if I break when you
play g5 or not so for example if you
play there in a plane 94 and then you
play rook there and somehow I was able
to play c5 right now without losing any
material I would say that white is doing
well because then I'm opening the
position and I'm bothering you on that
diagonal so typically if white is going
to be able to play c5 then black will
not play g5 that's typically what ends
up happening but in this position white
played an imprecise move in the opening
which was Queen b3 b3 really didn't make
sense like the Queen has nothing to do
there right in previous examples white
always put the Queen on the 2 and that
made a lot more sense besides it covered
this square makes it harder to achieve
this plan so in that case maybe the game
would have continued with Queen B 8 and
then would have been more familiar
anyway let's move on to the next example
okay I think this is an interesting one
so some of the examples that we have
been following a are part of the
Hedgehog chapter within my book this
example is one that I that was actually
played after the book was published so
completely separate ideas so let me show
you so it was a 4c 593 he seeks
now buy black played this 97 idea and
then g6 so that's kind of unusual it's
unusual because typically black plays
did the Bishop to e7 and then there are
some lines where the bishop can later go
to d8 and c7 and play on this diagonal
Bishop on g7 is kind of a completely
different plan now white here played c4
and then we have a relatively familiar
position now let me ask you a question
if you were black and you could
eliminate one of your opponent's minor
pieces which one would you eliminate
yeah the dark square Bishop right if you
could eliminate that Bishop then you're
interposition be very pleasant right you
can see the difference between these two
Bishop right Bishop on these three and
Bishop 25 which one is better yeah you
can see that so now in this game h6
obviously I want to chase that Bishop
and obviously you don't want to trade it
and now why black just played g5 which
is kind of brave we should move and now
95 now let's say that you just don't
want to kind of ignore this entire
situation play something like Bishop e2
then here with black I'm feeling pretty
good and then if you were to play
something like this then here I would be
pretty happy with black it's a pretty
original position right quite different
from things we have seen before but it
looks very nice I think black has a very
pleasant position and there are a lot of
imbalances which means it's not just
going to be a draw we can easily kind of
play for a win which is what we want to
do now why is this nice one of the main
reasons is this time night only file you
can see that night when a fire is very
nice very well placed so anyway the game
won't you know with 94
so 94 attacking this pawn then take take
take and then we have some trades and
here we are so after all these trades
how do you evaluate this position okay
now so you are you're saying that maybe
h6g fiber a little bit weaknesses right
how can white attack them yeah sure sure
so if we could if we could exchange it
all bishop see and then yes that would
be kind of a problem right
right now we like our Bishop 25 is a
pretty good vision so is that we should
went away and then this Queen somehow
ended up on h5 I would see why that
would be the case but right now I
actually think that black is doing a
little bit better something that you
have to know this is that the King on g1
is also a little bit weak it is that
I've gone a little bit more annoying and
overall the bishop on high is better
than the bishop on f2 and then there is
another interesting factor here which is
if we were to create a lot of things I
can more easily get my king to the
center or at least move it forward a
little bit so now black played nice move
aggressive Queen d2 okay we're bothering
any suggestions
oh no but it is black to play yeah
look see it I'm assuming F right yeah
sure so let's look at this old rock FC 8
let's say you play that then I assume
you want to play Roxy - that's a very
concerning threat
so how about I play rook d1 then maybe
Queen e2 I'll continue bothering you I
think eventually you will end up taking
your Queen away
maybe to b5 and then I might play
something like this and I might be a
little bit closer to equality still a
little bit better for black but that's
kind of the problem so let's see the
difference here artemyev just played
rock d8 so what's the difference you
can't push it away right you play this I
just take it now Queen a for preparing
right preparing to get the Queen out now
rook c8 so now let's examine this line
let's say you allow me to just play this
move then that's a win for black
essentially right because I play this
the next one Bishop d4 end of the game
so this game continues roughly 122
and what is this
much better fruit like right so
essentially the material is the same the
poni structure is almost the same but we
have managed to maintain our advantage
just because our pieces are better
coordinated so game continued rocky one
dreamy - Rudy - and now you can't defend
anymore right because if you play this
then I believe you're losing on the spot
of the bishop before so here black play
no white play Bishop d3 age 5 and then -
4 and then we the game ends after Queen
F - and the next three now why did all
of this happen because I mean when we
look at this it just looks like a
tactical accident but why did all of
this happen if you go back a little bit
something that you will notice is that
throughout the game the the weakness of
this diagonal was a permanent problem
right that was one of the biggest issues
yes earlier maybe yeah that's what that
that's one thing but another thing that
I want you to notice is that whenever
black manages to break in the center
which is effectively what happened here
then black will have a slight permanent
advantage because this f3 move is
undesirable okay so sometimes it is easy
to sort of get lost with all these
complications because okay we have this
position it's very messy to calculate
but the one thing to understand is that
if at the end of the day we end up
trading all the central pawns I will
have a little something just because you
have put the pawn on a three and that's
that's effectively what happened in this
game okay there were a lot of tactics
but at the end of the day like always
seem to be a little bit ahead because of
the weakness of the diagonal the other
diagonal and the King in general was
exposed
okay so say no okay I think now we
should take a short break because we
will have another lecturers friend in
like five minutes and I'm happy to
answer any questions you have
[Music]